so good morning or good afternoon or
good evening depending where you are
I'm John Quackenbush and I'm really
pleased to be here with you today
talking about some of the work that I
and my colleagues have been doing trying
to use Network methods to understand the
drivers of human biology and human
disease so I'm gonna talk about using
networks to understand cancer risk and
the work I'm going to present is all
about building models that try to
capture some of the complexity of human
disease and to use that complexity as a
way to really get at some of the drivers
in this case of cancer so we're gonna be
talking about modeling and I like to use
quotes in my talks one of my favorite
quotes is a quote from George box in
engineering you've probably seen this
George said essentially all models are
wrong but some models are useful and I
really like to think about this
especially when you get comments back
from referees who asked me you know how
do you know this model is right and my
answer is I don't know it's right but
what I do know is it informs my
understanding of the biology that I'm
studying they're going to come back to
that theme again and again as I talk
about this work today the models aren't
necessarily right but they do give us a
lot of insight so at the basis of all of
this these work that I and my colleagues
have been doing to try to understand how
we use genomic data and information to
really drive precision medicine so the
idea is actually fairly simple one of
the things that we recognized we could
start doing once we had the first human
genome sequence then once we expanded
our ability to generate genomic data was
that we could begin to use that data and
information in a way to understand the
entire life cycle of human disease
development progression and treatment so
if you look at this slide and start in
the lower left hand corner what we can
think about doing is looking at your
genome or my genome and understanding
our genetic risk of course that genetic
risk is going to be modified by things
like
our lifestyle the environment in which
we live but all of us carrying risk for
developing some disease and so what we'd
like to be able to do is to estimate
that risk so that we can make informed
decisions about our lifestyle choices
and also about how we think about doing
things like testing diagnosis and later
on disease management but having
assessed our genetic risk the next thing
we like to do is use genomic techniques
to do better early detection of disease
and we could talk about those that
people are interested in the question
period but once we detect disease what
we'd really like to be in a position to
do is to stratify patients and what that
means is we want to be able to look at
diseases which to a pathologist may look
identical but in fact we now are
potentially driven by different
molecular phenotypes different molecular
states so the whole goal of doing that
is really to begin to better stage
disease so to understand in cancer for
example how many mutations have
accumulated and what that means in terms
of the progression of the disease but
more importantly what we'd like to be
able to do is to match patients with
best treatment options with the ultimate
goal of improving both the quantity and
quality of their lives so in thinking
about this problem I am my colleagues
for years have been using data from
technologies like DNA microarrays but
over the last few years there's really
been an explosion of data and
information that we've been able to gain
by looking at genomic sequence data so
the question is how do we take this
genomic sequence data and use it most
effectively to be able to really execute
on this global strategy and a lot of
works been done over the past few years
in developing targeted therapies that
look at individual mutations in
particular in cancer that might be
associated with the development of
progression in his knees and to target
those cancer specific mutations in a way
that we hope will improve response so if
we look at the actual data what we
see is that for many of those targeted
therapies the responders the response
rate shown in black can be very high by
for example in Gleevec or
we're vitamin those two drugs actually
have very good response rates for
individuals who carry those mutations
but if we look at the rest of the
mutations what were the rest of the
drugs what we see is that it's really a
mixed bag and in some of them the vast
majority of individuals simply don't
respond and one of the other interesting
things we start to see is that for
individuals who don't carry the
mutations some of them still respond so
even though we have tests that look at
biomarkers that are supposed to direct
patients and therapies our ability to
match the patient to therapy still isn't
perfect and what that speaks to is in
fact a greater complexity of human
disease than we tend to think about it's
not just a single gene it's not just a
single mutation in fact disease is
driven by complex processes so the
answer to really resolving this question
of how we better match patients the
disease I would argue is captured in
data and what's really driven a lot of
our thinking about this is this cost
curve you've probably all seen for
sequencing the human genome when the
first genome was sequenced in 2000 2001
the cost of sequencing the genome was
estimated to be about a hundred million
dollars not too many of us could afford
that but by 2009 the cost had fallen to
about a hundred thousand dollars and
well look at that cost and look at that
period in time I would actually say then
that if my wife her son had a rare tumor
I would mortgage our house and sequence
their genome because even though our
understanding was incomplete there was
enough information that we actually
could have helped direct them to
potential therapies today the cost of
sequencing in genome is a few thousand
dollars and the way I like to think
about it is basically I can pay for that
genome on my credit card and what that
means functionally is
you or I are in a position where what we
could do is really imagine imagine
generating large quantities of genomic
data so there projects underway today
that are starting to amass those
population level sets of genomic data
but the question is how do we really
interpret it and the answer to that is
that we have to rely on all these other
sources of data and information so a lot
of the work I and my colleagues in
probably knew yourselves have been doing
over the years has involved taking
genomic data and matching it to
phenotype and in phenotype what that
often means are patient records but in
fact we recognize there's just a much
larger universe of data we can tie into
if we have the tools and methods to be
able to do it so I'm going to talk about
some of those tools and methods today
then what I really want to do is sort of
lay out the approach that we've taken
the thinking about building models that
capture this kind of complex data so
what we really want to do is use data to
drive discovery now a lot of people
think that this should be easy and I've
heard a lot of presentations over the
last few years where people say well you
know with advances in computing like
machine learning we should be able to do
is take all the data information shove
it into a computational engine and
extract meaningful data and information
but the problem that we've faced as a
community is that we often don't have
the right data in information to train
algorithms and we don't have large
enough datasets to be able to do that so
the canonical example people now people
often point to is IBM Watson for
oncology and if you look at Watson for
oncology it was really sold as a system
that once it won on Jeopardy could be
turned to dealing with the problem of
extracting information about diseases
like cancer and being able to match
individuals to therapies but in an
article that appeared in stat news in
2017
they actually likened Watson for
oncology to the Mechanical Turk and if
you're not familiar with the Mechanical
Turk it was a chess-playing robot in
Vienna Austria in the 1700s
you go down to the public square you'd
play the robot and you'd lose and if you
think about computer technology in the
seventeen hundreds there really wasn't
an advanced computing engine it would
allow an instrument to play chess and
beat you and what the Mechanical Turk
really had was a chess grandmaster
sitting out on the stage moving the
pieces and if you look at IBM or Watson
for oncology what this article does is
talks about the fact that IBM Watson for
oncology was driven by a set of
oncologist Memorial Sloan Kettering who
themselves were parsing the literature
and entering information but Watson
didn't have the capability of matching
all of the constraints and limitations
and biomarkers and other indications in
the studies to eventual therapies and so
it really wasn't a successful program
are nearly as successful as IBM had
hoped and the reason for this I think is
actually pretty simple one of my
favorite papers in computer science is a
paper that doesn't talk about machine
learning but it's a paper by Wolff pert
McCrady from 1997 that they call no free
lunch theorem for optimization and if
you read the introduction to this paper
it reads like an indictment of most
machine learning papers that I've read
over the last few years the past few
decades has seen an increased interest
in general-purpose blackbox optimization
algorithms that exploit limited
knowledge concerning the optimization
problem on which they're run and if you
go through the paper it actually
Provenza presents a pretty clear and
cogent argument that this use of
algorithms without other sources of data
and information and constraints the use
with small data sets and then the
attempt to generalize them to larger
data sets or other different types of
data sets is doomed to fail and so in
the conclusions what they do is they
talk about the demonstrated the danger
of comparing algorithms based on their
performance in small samples but more
importantly and this has really been a
driver of the work that I and my
colleagues have been doing over the last
few years what this really pointed to
was the idea
that they summarized in the last
sentence here highlighted these same
results indicate the importance of
incorporating problem specific knowledge
into the behavior of the algorithm
essentially what they argue for in this
paper is something akin to Bayesian
statistics what you want to do when
developing an algorithm is make a
rational guess you want to incorporate
something about the behavior of the
system into the underlying model they're
building so for my colleagues and I one
of the things we've been looking at is a
way to constrain the systems and
captures for them some of the complex
interactions between the many elements
in the cell is the use of networks as a
biological string now people who talk
about networks use the term pretty
loosely and if you look at the
biomedical literature there all sorts of
network representations of individual
types of data and all of those networks
actually represent different things so
what do we mean when we say we have a
network well a network is really a way
of representing complex Association
patterns between various entities and
those entities can be almost anything so
we like to draw little diagrams with
networks and shown on the left hand side
is a network in which we have a series
of nodes there are little balls numbered
one through six and a series of
connections between them we refer to
those as edges and the nice thing if you
want to do computation and analysis of
networks is we can transform those
drawings into physical representations
as a matrix so if I look at the network
on the left and I look at the bottom at
node number one I can see edges or
connections with itself and with two and
with five so nodes 1 2 & 5 are all
interacting if I look at the matrix I
can look at row number 1 and I can see a
series of ones and zeros and in fact the
ones are in column 1 column two and
column 5 and what that means is node 1
has an edge or an interaction with 1 2 &
5
right in the same way if I look at node
3 that has connections with 2 & 4 and if
I look at row 3 of this matrix I see 0
except in columns - in column or so the
matrix provides us with a really nice
mathematical representation of the
network but what does a one really mean
or what is an edge in my drawing me and
the challenge is that those edges can
actually represent almost anything that
we consider an interaction they can be
physical interactions like in
protein-protein interaction networks
where we know two proteins bind together
they can be regulatory interactions in
which we have a transcription factor
binding to and activating a gene or they
can be simple things like correlations
associations right a lot of people have
used correlation based networks to model
gene regulatory processes but they don't
really capture gene regulatory processes
all they capture is Co expression not
even Co regulation so we can represent
all different types of data and
information using a matrix and where you
can represent all different types of
networks using the same matrix where the
the networks can be as I mentioned a
variety of different things so I'm going
to talk about the kind of networks we
draw since those networks in fact are
distinct from many of the other networks
that you might see in the literature so
the way we approach network differences
their network analysis is to really
think not of a single network
representing all of biology but in fact
different networks representing
different phenotypes so a lot of the
analysis that we do we'll imagine having
collections of genes and individuals in
over whom we have measured some property
of those genes in this slide what you
can see is gene expression data
representing that representatives little
heat map but rather than inferring just
a single Network what we're going to try
to do is to infer individual networks by
first comparing those two phenotypic
groups and looking for differentially
expressed genes but then also pulling
out regulatory networks and when we pull
out those regulatory networks we're
going to do that for each one of the
individual phenotypes we examine and
we're going to look at the structure and
topology of the networks we're going to
compare
Aric topologies between phenotype a and
phenotype B and we're then going to link
those comparisons the differences in the
edges that appear disappear we're gonna
link those comparisons in the network
topology and structure to differential
expression to begin to explain the
phenotypes we observe and in fact what I
and my colleagues have been doing is
taking this idea even much farther
rather than just thinking about a
network for phenotype number one for
phenotype number two we actually
recognize that each individual in the
network each individual in the
population excuse me should have their
own individual networks and the
properties of those individual networks
in fact are distinct from one person to
another and those properties can be
correlated with things like disease risk
and disease state so this is the general
philosophy we've adopted for doing
network analysis in comparison and so
what I'm gonna do is really zero in on
one or two specific examples but the
core idea be quiet behind all the work
we do in looking at networks is that
biological systems are driven by these
complex networks which make looking at
individual elements like single genes or
single genetic variants extraordinarily
difficult and less than informative the
structure of the network is important
and the structure of that network
actually informs our understanding of
biology and the system that we're
studying as I said earlier there's no
single right network the network in each
tissue and each biological state and in
fact in each individual is unique so the
real question is not does the network is
the network wrong or right as they
alluded to earlier when talking about
Georges box the real question is does
the network inform our understanding of
the biological system we're trying to
study so my colleagues and I have
actually been building a whole host of
different Network methods and we refer
to them as the methodological zoo the
reason we call it the zoo is in fact
we've named all of our network models
after animals our very first network
method was one we called panda this was
developed largely by Kimberley glass
and in developing panda we wanted to
come up with a name that would be
memorable we decided we want to look at
animals and as you probably all know
there's no animal that's cuter than a
panda
so everybody remembers panda but in fact
we've gone on to develop lots of
different types of Network methods and
the reason we have so many of them is
that we develop different methods
depending on the input data so this
diagram is meant to capture all those
different methods I won't have time to
talk about all of them I'm going to
emphasize a lot of the presentation
today on a method that we developed
called Condor this was largely the work
of John platting but I'm gonna look at
Condor and I'm also going to briefly
mention two others panda and lioness at
the end but the topic of this talk was
really using networks to understand
cancer risk and so we're gonna be
looking at genetics and Condor was a way
of us trying to understand how genetic
factors influence our disease risk and
also disease development progression the
starting point for this was actually
work we did in chronic obstructive
pulmonary disease and it was really
driven by what we think of as a simple
question can we solve the G wasps puzzle
so as you probably all know G wasps is G
Watsons our genome-wide Association
studies and what we do is we take DNA we
look at genetic variant locations or
sniffs single nucleotide polymorphisms
we capture those snips by doing a
genome-wide assay and in each individual
region we look at genotypes at each of 6
million or more individual snip
locations and then we look at two
populations say a healthy population and
disease population and we simply ask is
illustrated on the bottom is there a
particular genetic variant that appears
more frequently than we'd expect by
chance in the disease population
relative to the normal population in
which case our hypothesis would be that
that genetic variant is associated with
Disney's risk now it seems like a
relatively simple
approach but in fact we start to look at
these genetic variants what we discover
is a lot of them have very small effect
sizes and one of my favorite papers
illustrating this was a paper that
appeared a few years ago by a group
called the giant consortium and they
looked at about 250,000 individuals and
they wanted to find genetic variants
that were associated with height
something we all know has a genetic
component when they looked at height
what they saw was there were about 700
snips that captured about 20% of the
variability we see in human height and
that in fact is they started to increase
the amount of variability they wanted to
see he needed almost 10,000 snips by
more than an order of magnitude increase
to explain 29% of height so what this
really points to is there are a lot of
genetic variants many of them have very
small effect sizes but they have to work
together in interesting ways to produce
the phenotypes that we see is height
alone no we can look at body mass index
body mass index this is another study by
the giant consortium slightly later than
the first
they had 340 thousand individuals they
found that 97 snips could explain about
3 percent of BMI and they argued that
all common snip so that six million
snips may only explain 20% of body mass
index looking at them snip by snip by
snip so the real question is how do we
approach these small effect sizes and I
would argue that well we've talked about
height and BMI these results can be
generally applied to any complex
phenotype including all almost all of
the diseases that we've studied so when
we start to look at these rare genetic
variants
well we certainly these genetic variants
and look at their small effect size the
real question is how do we interpret
what we're seeing do we give up on these
genome-wide Association studies despite
their success do we find map and
everything and look for rare variants or
do we think differently so I would argue
that we think differently there have
been a lot of people say we should look
for rare variants and I'll just point
out that there are some very nice
studies
that's suggesting that suggested those
rare variants are not the answer so
there was a paper that was published
about a year and a half ago by a large
consortium they looked at type 2
diabetes and in this analysis what they
concluded is that large sales
large-scale sequencing does not support
the idea that lower frequency variants
play a major role in a complex phenotype
in this Cape type 2 diabetes and there's
actually a really informative figure
figure one in the paper where they show
the models on the right and the observed
data on the left that really illustrates
the point that these rare variants are
not the drivers of disease so the
question then is how do we move beyond
these linear associations how do we
start to look at complex analyses and I
argued earlier that what we should be
doing is looking at networks so the
place where we started was by looking at
snips genetic variants and their
association with phenotypes that we can
measure quantitatively in a large scale
and now let's by looking at the
expression of genes so what we started
doing is what's known in the literature
is expression quantitative trait locus
analysis or eqtl analysis the idea here
is very simple and it builds on older
work that was done in quantitative trait
locus analysis the idea is that we look
at quantitative traits the expression of
all 25,000 or however many genes we
believe there are we look at the six
million genetic variants or more that we
can measure and we simply ask can we
associate genetic variants with the
expression levels of individual genes so
look at those gene expression levels as
quantitative traits and ask this very
simple question if I have a snip locus
at a particular point in the genome is
that locus tied or associated with the
expression level of that gene now most
people have concentrated on what we call
sis acting snips so if I have a gene
that's a snip that's immediately
adjacent to the gene but in fact we know
there are many other snips that are far
away in the genome that seem to
influence expression and that also are
increasingly
sheeted with disease risk and disease
development or what we call transacting
snips so we want to be able to look at
both both those snips that are nearby
achene where on the right and the
cartoon what we see is the genotype is
actually associated with the expression
level of that gene but we also don't
want to forget snips that are far away
potentially acting through moderating
the expression of transcription factors
or micro rna's such that or epigenetic
factors such that we also observe an
association between the genotype at a
particular locus wherever that might be
and the expression of the individual
genes such that we see a simple
relationship between them so what we
decided to do was take a large data set
and chronic obstructive pulmonary
disease from the lung genomics research
consortium or L GRC we performed a
standard eqtl analysis using a tool
called matrix equal TL looking for those
linear associations in both cysts and
transacting snips and that what we
decided to do was not just look at the
individual snips and genes in that by
themselves but in fact what we wanted to
do was to take those and look at complex
associations by representing those using
a network representation so we wanted to
take the Simpson jeans and look for
those statistically significant
associations between the genotype of
that snip in the expression level of the
gene so we decided to use what's called
a bipartite graph the difference between
a bipartite graph and the type of graph
that I showed you earlier was that in
the first node the first graph I drew
the nodes were all balls they were all
the same in some way in a bipartite
graph we imagine they're two different
types of nodes so you can think of them
like in this drawing as squares and
circles or snips and genes and the rule
for bipartite graph is that we only have
edges or associations between nodes of
one type and nose of
the other so in this case a snip can't
be connected to a snip or a gene can't
be connected to a gene we can only have
associations between snips and genes and
this is exactly the kind of analysis we
do in eqtl analysis we look for a snip
and we look for a gene that's associated
with it
so one snip can be associated with one
or many genes and one gene in its
expression levels can be associated with
one or many snips so a bipartite graph
is a really nice way of capturing these
many-to-many associations and it allows
them to capture us to capture both
assists in transacting associations in
one single graph so we publish an
analysis of this work in PLoS
computational biology a few years ago
and when we looked at the 6 million
snips and the the 25,000 genes what we
got was a whole set of associations now
whenever you draw or do a network
presentation or talk about networks
everyone always wants to see what the
network looks like this is actually not
the network in this paper this is just
some random hairball I grabbed from the
internet because most of the time look
at these diagrams don't tell you a whole
lot although this one does have some
interesting features if you look at it
you can start to see little communities
or groups of nodes that are pulled
together in chunks but in fact looking
at these diagrams are very very
difficult to interpret so what we try to
do is to take properties of those
diagrams and to represent them and talk
about those properties and the first
thing we talk about is what we call the
degree distribution so a degree
distribution is a simple way of
representing how many connections a
particular node has and in this case and
so we have two types of nodes snips and
genes we have to look at different
degree distributions for the snips and
for the genes so shown here on the left
in red we have the degree distribution
for the snips on the right the degree
distribution for the genes and what you
see is a plot of the log of the
frequency so how often we see things
versus the log the degree right so in
the upper left hand
we have lots and lots and lots of nodes
that have only one or a very small
number of connections right so they
occur frequently frequently and in the
bottom right hand corner of each of
these we see the small number of nodes
that have many many many connections
people often refer to this as a
scale-free distribution in fact it's not
exactly scale freeze what we formally
call a fat-tailed distribution but
they're the kind of distributions we
tend to see for naturally evolving
networks things like the Internet
right so down in the bottom in lower
right hand corner you have your googles
and Amazons and eBay's and Facebook's
that are connected to everything up in
the upper left hand corner what you see
are things like your laptop and there
are millions and millions and millions
of your laptops but they're very few
Google's and Amazon's and eBay's and
those things down in the lower right
hand corner the googles and Amazons are
what we refer to as the hubs and the
network you shut your laptop nobody
cares except maybe your mom who can't
Skype you but down in the lower right
hand corner
you know if somebody shuts down Google
for the day everybody's gonna freak out
so we have two different degree
distributions because we have these
different types of nodes and what we're
going to do is we're going to focus on
just for one of those we're gonna look
at the snip degree distribution so shown
here what you can see in black are is
the degree distribution for the snips
and the edges that come from those snips
and what we decided to do was to ask if
we map disease-associated snips to this
to this plot we asked ourselves where
are they going to land and when we
started to think about it we had hope
that a lot of these would land in the
hubs these are the places that are
highly connected that are associated
with the entire network the things that
are connected to everything but when we
map them what we discovered is that the
hubs
Archy wasps desert that none of the
snips associated through genome-wide
association studies with disease
actually mapped to the hubs
in a way this kind of makes sense
because earlier we talked about the fact
that most of these genetic variants have
small effect sizes and if they map to
the hub's you'd expect them to have a
very very big perturbative effect on the
network because they're connected to
everything right but what we see are
smaller perturbations and what's really
interesting when you look at this
diagram this is a slight under
representation of the leaves those
things with only a single connection and
there's an over-representation in the
middle of this graph so what this really
got us thinking about is the fact that
this graph itself may have some
additional structure so what we decided
to ask ourselves was can we use this
network to look for groups of snips and
genes that work together that play off
some structure and to do that what we
began to do was to try to group this
network together into communities that
reflect the overall grouping structure
that many networks have so to do that
what we did was we adapted a method that
had been developed for looking at for
communities in bipartite graphs and
there's a whole family of networks that
look for community structure and graphs
all networks have communities or most
networks have communities you look at
telecommunications you have a mobile
phone if I imagine you have a child and
a lot of spouse you call your spouse
your spouse because your son your son
calls your daughter your daughter calls
her grandmother your mother calls you
right and that set of connections
represents a family based community
because any two members of your family
are more likely to be associated or to
call each other on any given day then
they are to call a random person in the
outside world
right while you may one day call me
because you think this presentation is
brilliant your mom is never going to
call me right so you have a family
community defined by an increased
likelihood of connection in the same way
when we looked at these eqtl networks we
started to ask is there an increased
likelihood that there are a group of
snips and genes that are interconnected
and so we used a method based on what's
called modularity maximization can we
find sets
variants that are associated together so
John platic adapted a method called brim
for doing bipartite analysis and
extended it to these large-scale
networks and what we found is
represented here as one of those
adjacency matrices the matrices I showed
you earlier every role in this network
is a gene now in this matrix is a gene
every column is a snip and you can see
vertical stripes those vertical stripes
are in fact the the hub's those are the
snips that are connected to everything
but what's really striking about this is
not those vertical stripes but the fact
that we have these very tight and very
dense very modular communities and what
this really speaks to is the nature of
genetic disease that it's not a single
genetic variant that blows everything up
in fact it's a lot of small effect size
genetic variants that group together
with sets of genes the influence
function so if you start to think about
it that way then what do you start to
ask is do these communities have some
more informative structure so this is
another representation of the same
network I said I wouldn't draw a network
now I'm drawing a network this is a
representation comes out of cytoscape I
tend to think about this like
Botticelli's Venus it's a seashell it's
opening up to show you the beauty inside
lots of seashells lots of beauty but if
we look at this diagram what we see is
52 communities with a high degree of
modularity they're very tightly
connected internally and when we looked
at the 34 communities that are all
connected together so we threw out the
small ones that might be artifacts of
some of the data well we look at the 34
communities that are all connected
together what we see is most of them
have concentrations of biological
functions by looking at their genes and
the associated NGO terms and in fact 11
of those are significantly highly
enriched for particular biological
functions and if
look at those they're functions
associated with both lung development
and lung function as well as functional
disruptions that are associated with the
disease we were studying chronic
obstructive pulmonary disease so this
was very interesting but if we look at
this diagram the other thing we see is
that these individual communities have
their own local Hobbs right the global
hubs don't play a role the local hubs
are important
so John platic and I started talking
about this and we came up with the idea
that what we can do is we could find
local hops or what we call core snips
and we defined what we call a core score
and the core score is very simple
it's the modularity or the fraction of
the modularity that an individual snip
carries within its community so I talked
about a family calling each other
earlier the way I tend to think about
the course snips
is of course if is like the matriarch in
a family she's the one that holds the
family together despite the warring
factions that mine exists and if the
matriarch unfortunately dies the family
disintegrates breaks apart right these
are the individuals in a family that are
at the center in the same way we have
snips that are at the center and the
ones that hold these communities
together
and we call them the course snips so we
looked at our communities we've
calculated core scores for all of the
snips in the network and then we took a
set of disease-associated snips in this
case chronic obstructive pulmonary
disease
snips that were found in a meta-analysis
to be linked strongly linked through
genome-wide Association studies with
chronic obstructive pulmonary disease
and we asked where do they fall in the
network well we noticed two things the
first is they fall into communities that
have functions which we are associated
that we associate with chronic
obstructive pulmonary disease but more
important more interesting I think they
don't fall randomly within those
communities in fact what we see is they
fall at the core of their communities so
this little box plot represents on the
right disease associated snips I'm sorry
excuse me on the left
disease-associated snips and on the
right non disease-associated snips and
what we can see in chronic obstructive
pulmonary disease in this lung tissue
the disease associated snips have a
course for that's 20 times higher than
the average course or in the network
right
so not only are snips more likely to
fall into these disease linked
functional communities where they're at
the core of those communities and if you
think about this more globally and what
we're starting to learn from this model
it's not a single snip that influences a
trait it's a family of snips that work
with a gene a set of genes together
right or a family of snips that
influence a biological process and the
likelihood that a snip is going to be
found associated with that process
associated with that disease is tied to
how likely it is to disrupt that process
right a coarse snip is at the center of
its functional group which we would
assert means that it's a snip in that
community that's most likely to disrupt
the function of that community so this
starts to paint a really nice and rich
picture of how snips might influence
disease and disease risk right so as I
mentioned in most instances it's not a
single gene or a single variant that's
controlling a trait but a family of
variants that influence a process
disease associated snips map to
communities whose functions whose genes
have functions that make biological
sense course snips are far more likely
to be disease snips and the structure of
the network is informative in ways that
individuals snip gene associations
simply are not the other thing which is
interesting that we see is that tissue
specific processes occur in tissue
specific functional communities that are
nucleated around snips that occur in
tissue specific open chromatin and I
actually pulled this last little bullet
point out too early this is actually
reflected in a much larger study this is
a study that we did and published in
PNAS
a little over a year ago this study
actually looked in 13 different tissues
from a large project called gtex the
genotype tissue expression project we
worked with version 6 of the data there
were 449 individuals all of whom invent
genotypes and these individuals also
their autopsy samples the individuals
consented to have biopsies taken biopsy
samples were taken from as many as 53
different body sites and gene expression
data was generated using RNA see what we
did is we took the larger sets of gene
expression data because not every
individual had accessible tissue or RNA
seek data from all tissues but what we
were able to do is to take that data to
condense it and analyze it in a series
of papers that we've published over the
last few years but when we looked at the
the data we actually found 13 tissues
that had more than a hundred gene
expression profiles and so we used those
to do gene expression analysis using an
approach very similar to the approach
that I described earlier in each tissue
we looked at snips and genes we look for
associations using matrix ETTL we
represented them as a bipartite graph we
then did community detection using
modularity maximization we started to
look at the properties of the snips in
the individual communities so what we
found in all 13 tissues was there a
number of highly modular communities in
this slide I'm just going to call out
one of those this is heart left
ventricle and what we see on the right
hand side in black and blue is the
adjacency matrix organized into clusters
and on the bottom we see those little
seashell diagrams I showed earlier again
looking either one of these isn't that
informative we look at the structure of
the networks themselves their degree
distributions and things like the core
scores and what this slide shows is just
one example of the 13 tissues in
the top left panel what you can see is
that same kind of degree distribution
graph I showed you earlier
with the black line representing the
chi-wah snips and their degree all the
snips in the network in their degree and
the little blue dots above are the G
wasp trait associated snips and what you
can see is there's kind of a cut-off
around degree 10 so the lower left-hand
panel is actually a representation that
mod [ __ ] the first author and the
paper came up with and what mod decided
to do was to represent this as an
expected versus observed numbers of
snips the expected number being the
number we expect by looking at that
black line and what do you see is
something really interesting that
underscores that the likely community
structure that we found in these
networks what you see is sort of an
increase to this middle degree but above
about degree 10 boom there's nothing
right so we see that same kind of
property we saw before pointing to
structure we found that structure and
when we look at the core snips what we
see is that the core scores from the
jiwa snips now shown in the right-hand
panel the the jiwa snips shown in blue
have a statistically significantly much
higher core score than the other non
jiwa snips in the network and we see
this in heart left ventricle in fact we
see this in all 13 tissues so I'm just
gonna pull out a single line from this
set of graphs that appears in the
supplement to this paper and what you
see is that same kind of expected vs.
observed behavior or above the gree 10
you don't see anything if you look at
this paper what we see is this entire
story playing out in all 13 tissues so
Maude and John plotting and I started to
look at this and a lot of our interest
is in understanding cancer and we asked
ourselves well can we go back and look
at cancer and see what this tells us
about cancer risk because cancer is just
a complex trait and we can take cancer
and map it to these 13 different tissues
that we had explored so what does this
tell us what are these eqtl networks
tell us about cancer and cancer risk so
you can look at the genetic architecture
of cancer risk and what you see is that
there a lot of snips that have
relatively high allele minor allele
frequencies but the relative risk
associated with those is pretty small
right it's what we talked about earlier
the fact that most genetic variants are
tied to very very small risk profiles
very small relative risk and we see lots
of those if you start to get to even
modestly higher risk we see very few and
in fact in most cases almost no genetic
association with a strong association
with disease we see very few of them and
in many diseases we don't see any so
what we decided to do was to look at
these common variants using results that
were tabulated in the NIH G West catalog
and in doing that we pulled out a set of
cancer risk nips and we asked what the
properties were of those cancer risk
snips
what we find is that there are some
shown here in this pie chart in red that
are associated with coding variants and
genes or splice variants and genes and
many of those genes are the genes that
we think of as carrying a high risk if
they're mutated and many of these are
the coding genetic variants that are
current genes like p53 or k rostra these
are the cancer risk genes that the
cancer associated genes the aubergines
and tumor suppressor genes they're a
small number of cancer risk snips that
are synonymous mutations whose presents
may be associated with differences in
relative transcriptional efficiency but
what we find is there are a lot of snips
that map to the gene region shown in
blue the genic nanak sonic snips whose
functions we don't know
and there's a significant fraction of
those which are energetic and so we
started to ask ourselves can we look at
these and actually begin to characterize
those by looking at the types of
networks we could extract from the gtex
data and mapping these two functions and
functional groups within those networks
so in this case I'm going to talk about
skin and all you do is look at skin look
at the community structure and skin
again we see many different communities
some large some small and we can begin
to look at those communities and ask
what can we learn about cancer risk nips
where do they map in those communities
are they random are they concentrated in
certain places and what are the
functions associated with those cancer
risk snips we also want to know whether
or not these snips have any other
interesting properties in the context of
the network and it's interesting to
think about what genes they may be
targeting meaning which genes are
associated with these snips in the sense
that one would say these snips are
influencing or regulating the expression
of these genes so what we decided to do
was to look at the cancer risk snips not
surprisingly what we see is they're
concentrated in a small number of
communities and that's the same sort of
thing that we saw when looking at COPD
associated snips that the cancer the
disease associated snips aren't
scattered everywhere
but they're concentrated in communities
and communities whose functions start to
make sense now there are some
communities where we see an
overabundance of cancer risk nips and
we'd expect those small communities to
really have functions that we associated
with disease risk disease development
and disease progression when we start to
look at skin what we see is that most of
the cancer risk snips map to a very
small number of communities but in fact
they map to communities that have
functions like epithelial development
cell division and immunity and what we
know is that all three of those are
processes that are associated with
development of cancers like melanoma
most cancers have a cell division in
fact all cancers have a component of
disruption of cell division and cell
cycle processes most cancers we now know
disrupt the immune processes that would
eliminate the cancers and in skin
cancers it's an emphasis is an
epithelial cancer what we expect to see
is an association of those snips with
epithelial development what's really
interesting though is when we start to
ask what genes are targeted in these
individual communities we can take
cancer associated genes so longer genes
and tumor suppressor genes and we can
simply ask how many snips are targeting
cancer associated genes oncogenes and
tumor suppressor genes then what we find
is that almost no non cancerous snips
target these oncogenes and tumor
suppressor genes so the cancer risk tips
preferentially target those genes that
we think of as being the hallmarks of
cancer the drivers of the cancer they
aren't necessarily the driver mutations
but these are other genetic variants
that are associated with the regulation
of the expression of those driving
mutations or those driving oncogenes and
tumor suppressor genes so what we start
to see in this process in fact is when
we look at cancer risk snips we can look
at multiple cancers all the cancer risk
snips that map back to skin and what we
start to see is a picture that talks
about how cancer invades disease
progression and disease development and
we've really seen interesting
associations if you look at this diagram
this bubble plot of gene ontology terms
that are associated thing with things
like immune evasion and this is
something in fact we see in every single
cancer we've looked at
in this analysis but when we look at
epithelial cancers and look at skin what
we start to see are some interesting
associations that speak to epithelial
disease development and progression so
one of the other epithelial cancers that
we looked at was breast cancer and we
looked in skin because we didn't have
breast tissue breast data that we could
do this analysis in we didn't have
enough breast samples to be able to do
the eqtl analysis but what we found was
that breast cancer development and
progression is actually associated with
breast cancer risk snips that are linked
to epithelial development and that's
really interesting because it's kind of
what we'd expect to see that these
cancer risk snips in breast cancer right
aren't gonna disrupt processes
associated with the epithelial nature of
breast cancer so then the question you
would ask is well where do these snips
map not just in the context of the genes
they influence but also these overall
communities right communities like
epithelia development so again what we
did is we calculated the course scores
and looking at those course scores what
we found was that the cancer risk snips
now are not only associated with
anchored genes and tumor suppressor
genes but they're driven to the core of
their own individual communities so we
can look for course snips now in
individual communities in this case I'm
looking for course snips in skin
associate with epithelial development so
I look at the epithelial community I
find a high course for snip and what you
discover when you look at this high
course for snip it's is that it's
associated with oncogenes but also
associated with genes associated with
epithelial development and these genes
are genes which are known to be dis
regulated in epithelial cancer so what
we're starting to see
is a way in which we can think about how
genes and genetic variants are linked
together in the context of not general
disease only but also in somatically
driven diseases like cancer not only do
snips not only your snips associated
with on genes and tumor suppressor genes
they are associated the regulation of
those but they're also tied to the
regulation of other processes that give
us insight into how those diseases
development progress development
progress so what have we learned in
doing all of this well regulatory cancer
risk snips affect the expression Oaxaca
genes and tumor suppressor genes right
there associated with those but they
also collectively regulate or deregulate
groups of genes that are involved and
the recognition of damaged cells and
immune response and they're more likely
to affect the expression of many genes
involved in the same biological process
particularly if those biological
processes are ones that we would
associate in a direct way with disease
development progression so bipartite
eqtl networks can be used as a way to
characterize regulatory snips associated
trade some disease this analysis of
cancer is currently under review but as
with all our papers we publish them or
post them as soon as they're ready to be
submitted to bio archive so you can find
a more detailed description of the work
that I presented here at the end today
in the bio archive the link is shown
here as I mentioned this papers under
review all the software and pools are
available through github and links are
associated are presented in the paper on
the bio archive the last question I want
to touch on just very briefly and I'm
all you spend about two minutes on this
since we're running out of time is
pamela model and gene regulatory
processes i'm just gonna give you a
high-level overview but i want to point
to one other thing i think is very
interesting so I mentioned panda earlier
pandas away
Modelling gene regulatory processes so
it looks at the associations between
transcription factors and their targets
with the readout being the expression of
RNA so is there an RNA transcript that
we can see in a microarray or through a
gene expression analysis for that to
happen we need to recruit an RNA
polymerase construct to bind to the DNA
in the region of the gene and what that
really means typically is we have to
have transcription factors that bind to
the DNA that recruit this RNA polymerase
construct so what we can do is we can
model the interaction between a
transcription factor in its downstream
target and if we start with a guess as
to what that network looks like right go
back to the no free lunch theorem we
start with a guess as to what the
network looks like by mapping
transcription factors to the genome we
can take that initial guess and refine
it to represent the network's in
different phenotypes so you have a
healthy Network in a diseased Network or
a chemo resistant in a chemo sensitive
Network what we decided to do was to
look in colon cancer at lots of
different networks and understand their
properties and to really try to delve
into what those networks are telling us
so we've applied this in a lot of
different settings there lots more
applications papers that are appearing
but as I mentioned just a second ago we
applied this to look in colon cancer and
what we did was we asked is there a
difference between colon cancer and men
in colon cancer in women we know the
disease risk disease development disease
progression and response to therapy
exhibit sexual dimorphism that males and
females have a different natural history
of disease we took panda and we extended
it to ask about males and females and we
took it a step farther using a method we
call lioness that allows us to tease out
not just to a male and a female Network
but in fact networks for each individual
in the study so we have hundreds of
networks so we compared the networks in
men and women
you ask how are they different and among
the many different processes that we see
differentially regulated males and
females one of the most interesting is
differential regulation of drug
metabolism response right I mentioned
just a second ago that males and females
have different response to therapy and
by modeling complex gene regulatory
networks we saw a phenomenon that we
were unable to see by looking at simple
D a simple differential gene expression
by looking at differential gene
regulation we could start to see that
the structure of the network and its
properties led us to the point we can
start to understand why male and female
disease are different so what I hope
I've been able to do in the time we've
had is to convince you than many types
of network and that each one tells us
different things the network structure
itself is really important in matters
and things we can learn by looking at
the properties of the networks our
informative and the changes in network
structures help us identify many of the
drivers disease help us identify things
like therapeutic targets so what does
this tell you well if you want to take a
lesson away from this and free
everything I've told you just to
remember that biological systems are
complex and you should embrace their
complexity not shy away from it you want
to use your understanding of clinical
medicine and under underlying biology to
frame intelligent questions you're going
to ask of the data and you want to use
your understanding to inform the models
that you built like Wilbur McCready
suggested in the no free lunch there and
paper so you really want to use your
understanding of the biological system
to guide your analysis and
interpretation of the data so I open
with a quote I'm going to close with one
from Enrico Fermi Fermi was a physicist
my PhD was actually in physics this is
my favorite quote to use when I'm giving
a talk and I'm gonna share with you
Fermi said before I came here I was
confused about this subject after
listening to your lecture I am still
confused at a higher level so if I've
done my job and your hour was well-spent
what I've done is left you highly
confused
and I'd be happy to help eliminate some
of that confusion but I really hope that
you've gotten something and learned
something about this and understand how
we've been able to use eqtl QTL networks
to tease out some of the disease
associations that we tie back to cancer
and disease risk let me associate with
cancer so I just want to close by
pointing out that this work is actually
work of a really huge team of people
have worked together to do this network
analysis on the right hand side Maude
Fagin II was really the driver of the
cancer risk analysis that we did she and
John platic did the analysis of gtex
John in the center was actually somebody
he's down Freeman women's a Channing
Division of network medicine was someone
who really helped drive the development
of Condor this method that we've used to
uh to represent and use dqt on that
works but in fact every single person on
the slide contributed in one way or
another to all of the analysis that we
presented we have a big group and team
that work together all of our methods
get published in bio archive they're all
released with open source software so I
invite you to reach out to me to reach
out to any of these people on the slide
and to look at and use these methods
because complexity is something we can
use to tease out truth from complex
biological systems by using Network
methods so thank you very much I'm happy
to answer questions I apologize this may
have run a little bit long but I hope
you liked the story head to toe thank
you